Alcohol and energy drinks are a match made
in HELL!
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and if you’re
someone over the age of 21, who frequents
dance clubs - then chances are, you’ve probably
combined alcohol and energy drinks at least
once in your life.
It makes sense, right?
You’re tired, and you have no energy - but
you still wanna party.
Well, stop doing that - cause according to
science, it’s bad for your health.
The rate of emergency rooms visits involving
energy drinks has doubled between 2007 and
2011, prompting the FDA to ban most pre-mixed
alcoholic energy drinks.
Unfortunately, that ban doesn’t extend to
bars - who still happily serve customers all
kinds of alcoholic energy drink concoctions.
A 2012 study found that people who combine
energy drinks with alcohol were 600% more
likely to suffer from heart palpitations,
and 400% more likely to suffer from tremors,
irritability, and insomnia - than people who
drink alcohol alone.
But heart problems aren’t the only side
effect of doing this.
There are also psychological effects that
explain why this combination is so bad for
your body.
Numerous studies have shown that mixing energy
drinks and alcohol not only increases your
likelihood of being in an accident, it also
impairs your judgment in two key ways: by
making you think you’re less drunk than
you actually are, and by making you crave
alcohol more strongly.
A series of experiments published in 2012,
found that people who consumed alcoholic energy
drinks rated their own intoxication as being
lower - than people who had identical blood
alcohol levels, but with no energy drinks.
Other studies have also shown that people
who have alcoholic energy drinks, tend to
consume more alcohol and drink for longer
- partly because the caffeine buzz, which
can last for up to 6 hours - eliminates those
feelings of tiredness that usually cause someone
to stop drinking.
Even sodas, which contain significantly less
caffeine than energy drinks - have been shown
to heighten intoxication.
And in fact, diet sodas - will get you drunk
even faster, because there’s no sucrose
there to slow down the gastric emptying of
alcohol.
So the next time you’re at the club and
decide you need to perk up - just don’t.
The added energy just isn’t worth it.
What are you thoughts on this?
Do you frequently mix energy drinks with alcohol?
and how does doing so, make you feel?
Feel free to share your experiences with us
in the comments down below - otherwise, thanks
for watching!